- Threat of entry.
How protected is an industry
from new firms entering it?
The threat of new entrants
getting into an industry
and capturing a share of its profitability
depends on how easy or difficult
it is for them to enter.
If it costs little in
terms of time or money
to enter a market and
to compete effectively
then they will do so and
capture profits for themselves.
This will lower the average
level of profitability
earned by firms in the industry.
If an industry has strong and difficult
to overcome entry barriers
then it will be able to
discourage new entrants
and protect its profit streams.
Simply put, industries
that earn high profits
typically attract a lot of attention.
But, industries that earn high profits
over long periods of time tend to do so
because they have done things
to keep other firms out.
What are barriers to entry?
Barriers to entry are unique
industry characteristics
that define the industry, or simply put,
firms in the industry
are able to do things
that entrants cannot do at
the same level of efficiency
or at the same costs.
Barriers to entry reduce
the likelihood of entry
by new firms and in so doing
maintain levels of profits.
There is no exhaustive simple
list of entry barriers,
they take many different
forms and are often unique
to different industries, however,
some of the main categories
of entry barriers are
patents and proprietary knowledge,
patents, copyright,
trademark and firm secrets
prevent others from using the knowledge
in entering the industry.
For example, Polaroid kept Kodak
out of the instant camera market
by suing it for patent
infringement and won.
When innovators prevent
potential competitors
from gaining their knowledge
they can prevent imitation.
Legal and regulatory barriers.
Government sometimes
creates barriers to entry.
When a city licenses taxis and has a limit
on the number of licenses,
this is an entry barrier.
Interestingly however, Uber
has recently found a way
around the barrier to
entry in the taxi market.
Governments often grant firms,
considered to have natural
monopolies, exclusive rights.
For example, telephone companies
were given exclusive rights
to offer phone services to communities,
because cities did not
want multiple phone lines
being strung up and down the streets.
It made no economic sense to
have multiple phone companies
serving the same communities.
Of course today things have changed.
Economies of scale and scope.
If minimum efficient scale
to operate in an industry
is large, relative to
the size of the market,
this may discourage entry
if there are already a few
large competitors in the market.
New entrants will know
that they will likely
have a difficult time
gathering enough market share
from incumbents to break even.
Producer learning.
It is well-known that
manufacturers become more efficient
because experience gained
from producing lots and lots
of products over long periods of time.
BCG, the Boston Consulting Group,
has estimated that with every doubling
of cumulative production
costs fall approximately 20%.
So, a prospective entrant
may be discouraged
from entering a market because incumbents
have strong experience and
learning curve advantages.
Brand and reputation.
Many products cannot be
easily evaluated by a buyer
until they have been purchased and used.
In these situations, new buyers
will observe other consumers
and their satisfaction level
with products that they have purchased.
Well-established brands
and firm reputations
work to reduce potential
customer dissonance.
Simply put, when I can't
evaluate the product
without buying it first and
I'm somewhat risk-averse,
I will likely buy a recognized brand.
In this way, brand and firm reputation
can become barriers to entry.
Advertising and channel crowding.
Early entrants into an industry often face
less crowded advertising message spaces
and distribution channels.
What is the likelihood of
being able to introduce
a new hot dog into the marketplace today?
Supermarket shelves are
already full of hot dogs.
There's a real question
as to where that new TV
and or print advertising
would be effective enough
to catch people's attention,
especially people who already
have a favorite hot dog.
What is the likelihood that
they choose a new brand?
Clearly it would be possible to do this
if you are willing to spend
unlimited amounts of money.
But this is where the
entry barrier occurs.
New entrants cannot, sometimes,
get into a market without
spending more to enter
then they would earn
operating in the industry.
The same is the case with access
to channels of distribution.
Distributors have only a
limited amount of capacity
for different SKUs, as do supermarkets
with limited shelf space.
Those that get in early, sometimes,
have insurmountable advantages.
Switching costs.
When users most make
significant investments
of their own time and
money to use a product
or a service they become stuck,
they cannot easily and costlessly
use a new product or service.
Even a more superior product
may not make traction
in a market because
customers are locked in
to existing products.
Retaliation.
The threat of aggressive
retaliatory action
by industry incumbents
can be a strong deterrent
to potential entrants.
When industry players signal
that they would aggressively drop price,
ramp up production and fill channels
or fight with lawsuits, valid or made up,
this can block entry.
Again, this is not an exhaustive
list of entry barriers.
Anything that makes it difficult
for prospective entrants
to imitate without large
investments of time or money
can act as a barrier to entry.